el funeral del duque de edimburgo será
el próximo sábado 17 de abril en el
castillo de windsor será una ceremonia
privada aunque se ha anunciado que habrá
un minuto de silencio a las tres de la
tarde en la que se espera que el público
en general en todo el país se una a este
minuto para rendir tributo al duque de
edimburgo por su rol dentro de la
familia real por su labor filantrópica
pero especialmente por ser el esposo de
la reina su columna vertebral y como la
han descrito muchos en el día de hoy la
roca de la monarca británica se ha
pedido que el público en general no se
una a este funeral no asista hasta
windsor para evitar aglomeraciones dadas
las restricciones que se mantienen en el
país por la pandemia del hobbit 19 se ha
confirmado también que el príncipe harry
quien se dice es el favorito era el
favorito del duque de edimburgo y de la
reina isabel viajará desde los eeuu
desde
ciudad donde reside ahora en california
para unirse a su familia para el funeral
de su abuelo su esposa mega marco y
quien está embarazada más de siete meses
posiblemente no viajar a no viajar a
megan mar coll aquí al reino unido para
unirse a esta ceremonia también el
gobierno británico ha anunciado que
hasta el ese día el sábado 17 habrá un
periodo de luto nacional en el que todas
las banderas de los edificios públicos
se izarán a media asta y habrá una serie
de conmemoraciones como el parlamento
volverá a sus funciones el próximo lunes
para rendir tributo a la memoria del
duque de edimburgo la ceremonia será
privada el duque expresó durante vida
que preferiría un funeral de tipo
militar para recordar sus años como
piloto de la armada nacional carrera
especialmente exitosa durante los años
50 y también en la segunda guerra
mundial
hoy la jornada del segundo día de luto
nacional estuvo marcada por muchos
tributos homenajes que ha rendido el
público en general quienes se han
acercado a que las afueras del palacio
de buckingham a dejar flores para rendir
homenaje a la memoria del duque pero
también para enviar un mensaje de
fortaleza a la reina isabel quien en los
próximos días el 29 de abril cumplirá 95
años quieren enviar expresar las
condolencias a la reina isabel y en
general a toda la familia real